[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Well, so
far in this course
we've been talking
about procedures,
and then just to remind
you of this framework
that we introduced for
talking about languages,
we talked about the
primitive things that
are built into the system.
We mentioned some
means of combination
by which you take
the primitive things
and you make more
complicated things.
And then we talked about
the means of abstraction,
how you can take those
complicated things
and name them so you can use
them as simple building blocks.
And then last time you saw
we went even beyond that.
We saw that by using
higher order procedures,
you can actually express general
methods for computing things.
Like the method
of doing something
by fixed points, or
Newton's method, and so
the incredible
expressive power you
can get just by combining
these means of abstraction.
And the crucial
idea in all of this
is the one that we
build a layered system.
So for instance, if we're
writing the square root
procedure, somewhere the
square root procedure
uses a procedure
called good-enough,
and between those there is some
sort of abstraction boundary.
It's almost as if we go out
and in writing square root,
we go and make a
contract with George,
and tell George that his
job is to write good-enough,
and so long as
good-enough works,
we don't care what it does.
We don't care exactly
how it's implemented.
There are levels of
detail here that are
George's concern and not ours.
So for instance, George might
use an absolute value procedure
that's written by Harry, and
we don't much care about that
or even know that,
maybe, Harry exists.
So the crucial idea is that
when we're building things,
we divorce the task
of building things
from the task of
implementing the parts.
And in a large
system, of course,
we have abstraction barriers
like this at lots, and lots,
and lots of levels.
And that's the idea that we've
been using so far over and over
in implementing procedures.
Well, now what we're
going to do is look
at the same issues for data.
We're going to see that the
system has primitive data.
In fact, we've
already seen that.
We've talked about
numbers as primitive data.
And then we're going to see
their means of combination
for data.
There's glue that allows you
to put primitive data together
to make more complicated,
kind of compound data.
And then we're going to see
a methodology for abstraction
that's a very good thing to use
when you start building up data
in terms of simpler data.
And again, the key
idea is that you're
going to build the
system in layers
and set up abstraction
barriers that
isolate the details
at the lower layers
from the thing that's going
on at the upper layers.
The details at the lower layers,
the ideas, they won't matter.
They're going to
be George's concern
because he signed this
contract with us for how
the stuff that he
implements behaves,
and how he implements
the thing is his problem.
All right, well let's
look at an example.
And the example I'm
going to talk about
is a system that does
arithmetic on rational numbers.
And what I have in mind is
that we should have something
in the computer that
allows us to ask it, like,
what's the sum of 1/2 and
1/4, and somehow the system
should say, yeah, that's 3/4.
Or we should be able to
say what's 3/4 times 2/3,
and the system should be able
to say, yeah, that's 1/2.
Right?
And you know what
I have in mind.
And you also know how to
do this from, I don't know,
fifth grade or sixth grade.
There are these
formulas that say
if I have some fraction which is
a numerator over a denominator,
and I want to add that to
some other fraction which
is another numerator
over another denominator,
then the answer is the
numerator of the first times
the denominator of the
second, plus the numerator
of the second times the
denominator of the first.
That's the numerator
of the answer,
and the denominator
is the product
of the two denominators.
Right?
So there's something from
fifth or sixth grade fraction
arithmetic.
And then similarly, if I
want to multiply two things,
n1 over d1 multiplied
by n2 over d2
is the product of the
numerators over the product
of the denominators.
So it's no problem at all,
but it's absolutely no problem
to think about what
computation you
want to make in adding and
multiplying these fractions.
But as soon as we
go to implement it,
we run up across something.
We don't have what a
rational number is.
So we said that the system
gives us individual numbers,
so we can have 5 and
3, but somehow we
don't have a way
of saying there's
a thing that has both a 3 and
a 4 in it, or both a 2 and a 3.
It's almost as if we'd like
to imagine that somehow there
are these clouds,
and a cloud somehow
has both a numerator
and a denominator in it,
and that's what we'd
like to work in terms of.
Well, how are we going
to solve that problem?
We're going to
solve that problem
by using this incredibly
powerful design
strategy that you've already
seen us use over and over.
And that's the strategy
of wishful thinking.
Just like before when we didn't
have a procedure, we said,
well, let's imagine that that
procedure already exists.
We'll say, well, let's imagine
that we have these clouds.
Now more precisely
what I mean is
let's imagine that we
have three procedures,
one called make-RAT.
make-RAT is going to take
as arguments two numbers,
so I'll call them
numerator and denominator,
and it'll return for us a
cloud-- one of these clouds.
I don't really know
what a cloud is.
It's whatever make-RAT
returns, that's its business.
And then we're going
to say, suppose
we've got one of these clouds,
we have a procedure called
numer, which takes in a cloud
that has an n and a d in it,
whatever a cloud is, and I don't
know what it is, and returns
for us the numerator part.
And then we'll assume we
have a procedure denom,
which again takes
in a cloud, whatever
a cloud is, and returns for us
the denominator [? required. ?]
This is just like
before, when if we're
building a square
root, we assume
that we have good enough.
Right?
And what we'll say is,
we'll go find George,
and we'll say to George,
well, it's your business
to make us these procedures.
And how you choose to
implement these clouds,
that's your problem.
We don't want to know.
Well, having pushed this
task off onto George,
then it's pretty easy
to do the other part.
Once we've got the
clouds, it's pretty easy
to write the thing that does say
addition of rational numbers.
You can just say define,
well, let's say +RAT.
Define +RAT, which will take in
two rational numbers, x and y.
x and y are each these clouds.
And what does it do?
Well, it's going to return
for us a rational number.
What rational number is it?
Well, we've got
the formulas there.
The numerator of it is the sum
of the product of the numerator
of x and the denominator of y.
It's one thing in the sum.
And the other thing
in the numerator
is the product of the numerator
of y and the denominator of x.
The star, close the plus.
Right, that's the first
argument to make-RAT,
which is the numerator of
the thing I'm constructing.
And then the rest
of the thing goes
into make-RAT is the
denominator of the answer, which
is the product of
the denominator of x
and the denominator of y.
Like that.
OK?
So there is the analog of
doing rational number addition.
And it's no problem
at all, assuming
that we have these clouds.
And of course, we can do
multiplication in the same way.
Define how to get the product
of two rational numbers,
call it *RAT.
Takes in two of these
clouds, x and y, it returns
a rational number,
make-RAT, whose numerator
is the product of the
numerators-- numerator of x
times the numerator of y.
And the denominator of the
thing it's going to return
is the product of
the denominators.
Well, except that I haven't
told you what these clouds are,
that's all there is to it.
See, what did I do?
I assumed by wishful
thinking that I
had a new kind of data object.
And in particular,
I assumed I had ways
of creating these data objects.
Make-RAT creates
one of these things.
This is called a constructor.
All right, I have a thing that
constructs such data objects.
And then I assume I have things
that, having made these things,
I have ways of
getting the parts out.
Those are called selectors.
And so formally, what
I said is I assumed
I had procedures
that are constructors
and selectors for
these data objects,
and then I went
off and used them.
That's no different
in kind from saying
I assume I have a
procedure good-enough,
and I go use it to
implement square root.
OK, well before we
go on, let's ask
the question of why do we want
to do this in the first place?
See, why do we want a procedure
like +RAT that takes in two
rational numbers and
returns a rational number?
See, another way to think
about this is, well,
here's this formula.
And I've also got to
implement something
that adds rational numbers.
One other way to think about
is, well, there's this thing,
and I type in four
numbers, an n1, and a d1,
and an n2, and a d2.
And it sets some
registers in the machine
to this numerator
and this denominator.
So I might say,
well, why don't I
just add rational
numbers by I type in four
numbers, numerators
and denominators,
and get out two
numbers, which is
a numerator and a denominator.
Why are we worrying
about building things
like this anyway?
Well, the answer
is, suppose you want
to think about expressing
something like this,
suppose I'd like to
express the idea of taking
two rational numbers,
x plus y, say,
and multiplying that by the sum
of two other rational numbers.
Well, the way I do it, having
things like +RAT and *RAT,
is I'd say, oh yeah, what
that is is just the product.
That's *RAT of the sum of x
and y and the sum of s and t.
So except for syntax,
I get an expression
that looks like the
way I want to think
about it mathematically.
I want to say there
are two numbers.
There's a thing which
is the sum of them,
and there's a thing which
is the sum of these two.
That's this and this.
And then I multiply them.
So I get an expression that
matches this expression.
If I did the other
thing, if I said,
well, the way I want
to think about this
is I type into my machine
four numbers, which
are the numerators and the
denominators of x and y,
and then four more numbers,
which are the numerators
and denominators of s and t.
And then what I'd be sitting
with is, well, what would I do?
I'd add these, and
somehow I'd have
to have two temporary variables,
which are the numerators
and denominators of
this sum, and I'd
go off and store them someplace.
And then I'd go over here,
I'd type in four more numbers,
I'd get two more
temporary variables,
which are the numerators
and denominators of s and t.
And then finally, I put those
together by multiplying them.
You see, what's
starting to happen,
there are all these
temporary variables, which
are sort of the guts
of the internals
of these rational numbers
that start hanging
out all over the system.
And of course, if I had more and
more complicated expressions,
there'd be more and
more guts hanging out
that confuse my programming.
And those of you who
sort of programmed things
like that, where you're just
adding numbers in assembly
language, you sort
of see you have
to suddenly be concerned with
these temporary variables.
But more importantly than
confusing my programming,
they're going to
confuse my mind.
Because the whole
name of this game
is that we'd like the
programming language to express
the concepts that we
have in our heads,
like rational numbers are things
that you can add and then take
that result and multiply them.
Let's break for questions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I don't
quite see the need-
when we had make-RAT with the
numerator and denominator,
we had to have the numerator
and denominator to pass
as parameters to
create the cloud,
and then we extracted to
get back what we had to have
originally.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So the question
is, I sort of have
the numerator and
the denominator,
why am I worrying about
having the cloud given that I
have to get the pieces out?
That's sort of what I
tried to say at the end,
but let me try and say it
again, because that's really
the crucial question.
The point is, I want to carry
this numerator and denominator
around together all the time.
And it's almost as
if I want to know,
yeah, there's a numerator
and denominator in there,
but also, I would like to say,
fine, but from another point
of view, that's x.
And I carry x around, and I
name it as x, and I hold it.
And I can say things
like, the sum of x and y,
rather than just have-- see,
it's not so bad when I only
think about x, but if
I have a system with 10
rational numbers, suddenly
I have 20 numerators
and denominators, which
are not necessarily--
if I don't link
them, then it's just
20 arbitrary
numbers that are not
linked in any particular way.
It's a lot like saying, well,
I have these instructions
that are the body
of the procedures,
why do I want to package them
and say it's the procedure?
It's exactly the same idea.
No?
OK.
Let's break, let's just stretch
and get somebody-- [INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, well, we've been working on
this rational number arithmetic
system, and then what we
did, the important thing
about what we did, is we
thought about the problem
by breaking it into two pieces.
We said, assume there is
this contract with George,
and George has
figured out the way
to how to construct
these clouds,
provided us procedures
make-RAT, which
was a constructor,
and selectors, which
are numerator and denominator.
And then in terms
of that, we went off
and implemented addition
and multiplication
of rational numbers.
Well, now let's go look
at George's problem.
How can we go and
package together
a numerator and a
denominator and actually make
one of these clouds?
See, what we need is a kind of
glue, a glue for data objects
that allows us to
put things together.
And Lisp provides such
a glue, and that glue
is called list structure.
List structure is a
way of gluing things
together, and more
precisely, Lisp
provides a way of constructing
things called pairs.
There's a primitive operator
in Lisp called cons.
We can take a look at it.
There's a thing called cons.
Cons is an operator which
takes in two arguments called
x and y, and it returns for
us a thing called a pair.
All right, so a thing called
a pair that has a first part
a second part.
So cons takes two objects.
There's a thing called a pair.
The first part of the cons is x,
and the second part of the cons
is y.
And that's what it builds.
And then we also assume we have
ways of getting things out.
If you're given a pair,
there's a thing called car,
and car of a pair,
p, gives you out
the first part of the pair, p.
And there's a thing called
cdr, and cdr of the pair, p,
gives you the second
part of the pair, p.
OK, so that's how
we construct things.
There's also a conventional
way of drawing pictures
of these things.
Just like we write down that as
the conventional way of writing
Plato's idea of two,
the way we could
draw a diagram to represent cons
of two and three is like this.
We draw a little box.
And so here's the box
we're talking about,
and this box has two
arrows coming out of it.
And say the first part
of this pair is 2,
and the second part
of this pair is 3.
And this notation
has a name, it's
called box and pointer notation.
By the way, let me say right
now that a lot of people
get confused that
there's some significance
to the geometric way I drew
these pointers, the directions.
Like some people think
it'd be different
if I took this pointer
and turned it up here,
and put the 3 out here.
That has no significance.
All right?
It's merely you have
a bunch of arrows,
these pointers, and the boxes.
The only issue is how
they're connected,
not the geometric
arrangement of whether I
write the pointer
across, or up, or down.
Now it's completely
un-obvious, probably,
why that's called
list structure.
We're not actually going
to talk about that today.
We'll see that next time.
So those are pairs, there's
cons that constructs them.
And what I'm going to know
about cons, and car, and cdr,
is precisely that if I have
any x and y, all right,
if I have any things x and y,
and I use cons to construct
a pair, then the
car of that pair
is going to be x,
the thing I put in,
and the cdr of that
pair is going to be y.
That's the behavior of these
operators, cons, car, and cdr.
Given them, it's
pretty clear how
George can go off and
construct his rational numbers.
After all, all he
has to do-- remember
George's problem was to
implement make-RAT, numerator,
and denom.
So all George has
to do is say define
make-RAT of some n and a d-- so
all I have to do is cons them.
That's cons of n and d.
And then if I want
to get the numerator
out, I would say define
the numerator, numer,
of some rational number, x.
If the rational number's
implemented as a pair,
then all I have to do
is get out the car of x.
And then similarly, define the
denom is going to be the cdr,
the other thing I
put into the pair.
Well, now we're in business.
That's a complete implementation
of rational numbers.
Let's use it.
Suppose I want to say,
so I want to think
about how to add 1/2 plus 1/4
and watch the system work.
Well, the way I'd use that is
I'd say, well, maybe define a.
I have to make a 1/2.
Well, that's a rational
number with numerator 1
and denominator 2, so a
will be make-RAT of 1 and 2.
And then I'll construct the 1/4.
I'll say define d to
be make-RAT of 1 and 4.
And if I'd like to look
at the answer-- well,
assuming I don't have a special
thing that prints rational
numbers, or I could make one--
I could say, for instance,
define the answer to be +RAT
of a and b, and now I can say,
what's the answer?
What are the numerators and
denominators of the answer?
So if I'm adding
1/2 and 1/4, I'll
say, what is the
numerator of the answer?
And the system is going
to type out, well, 6.
Bad news.
And if I say what's the
denominator of the answer,
the system's going
to type out 8.
So instead of what
I would really like,
which is for it to say
that 1/2 and 1/4 is 3/4,
this foolish machine is
going to say, no, it's 6/8.
Well, that's sort of bad news.
Where's the bug?
Why does it do that, after all?
Well, it's the way
that we just had +RAT.
+RAT just took the-- it said
you add the numerator times
the denominator, you add
that to the numerator times
the denominator, and put that
over the product of the two
denominators, and
that's why you get 6/8.
So what was wrong with our
implementation of +RAT?
What's wrong with that rational
number arithmetic stuff
that we did before the break?
Well, the answer is
one way to look at it
is absolutely nothing's wrong.
That's perfectly
good implementation.
It follows the sixth grade,
fifth grade mathematic
for adding fractions.
One thing we can say is,
well, that's George's problem.
Like, boy, wasn't
George dumb to say
that he can make a
rational number simply
by sticking together the
numerator and the denominator?
Wouldn't it be
better for George,
when he made a rational
number, to reduce
the stuff to lowest terms?
And what I mean is, wouldn't
it be better for George,
instead of using this
version of make-RAT,
to use this one on the slide?
Or instead of just saying cons
together n and d, what you do
is compute the greatest
common divisor of n and d,
and gcd is the procedure
which, well, for all we
care is a primitive, which
computes the greatest
common divisor of two numbers.
So the way I can construct
a rational number is
get the greatest common
divisor of the two numbers,
and I'm going to
call that g, and then
instead of consing
together n and d,
I'll divide them through.
I'll cons together
the quotient of n
by the the gcd and the
quotient of d by the gcd.
And that will reduce
the rational number
to lowest terms.
So when I do this addition,
when +RAT calls make-RAT--
and for the definition of +RAT
it had a make-RAT in there--
just by the fact that
it's constructing that,
the thing will get reduced to
lowest terms automatically.
OK, that is a complete system.
For rational number arithmetic,
let's look at what we've done.
All right, we said we want
to build rational number
arithmetic, and we had
a thing called +RAT.
We implemented that.
And I showed you multiplying
rational numbers,
and although I didn't
put them up there,
presumably we'd like
to have something
that subtracts rational
numbers, and I don't know,
all sorts of things.
Things that test equality in
division, and maybe things that
print rational numbers
in some particular way.
And we implemented
those in terms of pairs.
These pairs, cons, car, and
cdr that are built into Lisp.
But the important thing is
that between these and these,
we set up an
abstraction barrier.
We set up a layer
of abstraction.
And what was that
layer of abstraction?
That layer of abstraction
was precisely the constructor
and the selectors.
This layer was make-RAT,
and numer, and denom.
This methodology, another
way to say what it's doing,
is that we are separating
the way something is used,
separating the use
of data objects,
from the representation
of data objects.
So up here, we have the way
that rational numbers are used,
do arithmetic on them.
Down here, we have the way
that they're represented,
and they're separated
by this boundary.
The boundary is the
constructors and selectors.
And this methodology has a name.
This is called data abstraction.
Data abstraction is sort of
the programming methodology
of setting up data objects
by postulating constructors
and selectors to isolate
use from representation.
Well, so why?
I mean, after all, we didn't
have to do it this way.
It's perfectly possible to
do rational number addition
without having any compound data
objects, and here on the slide
is one example.
We certainly could
have defined +RAT,
which takes in things
x and y, and we'll say,
well what are these
rational numbers really?
So really, they're just
pairs, and the numerator's
the car and the denominator's
the cdr. So what we'll do
is we'll take the car of x times
the cdr of y, multiply them.
Take the car of y times the
cdr of x, multiply them.
Add them.
Take the cdr of x
and the cdr of y,
multiply them, and then
constitute together.
Well, that sort of
does the same thing.
But this ignores the
problem of reducing things
to lowest terms, but let's not
worry about that for a minute.
But so what?
Why don't we do it that way?
Right?
After all, there are sort of
fewer procedures to define,
and it's a lot more
straightforward.
It saves all this
self-righteous BS
about talking about
data abstraction.
We just sort of do it.
I mean, who knows, maybe it's
even marginally more efficient
depending on whatever
compiler were using for this.
What's the point of
isolating the use
from the representation?
Well, it goes back to
this notion of naming.
Remember, one of the
most important principles
in programming is
the same as one
of the most important principles
in sorcery, all right?
That's if you have the
name of the spirit,
you get control over it.
And if you go back
and look at the slide,
you see what's in there is
we have this thing +RAT,
but nowhere in the system,
if I have a +RAT and a -RAT
and a *RAT, and things
that look like that,
nowhere in the system do I
have a thing that I can point
at which is a rational number.
I don't have, in a
system like that,
the idea of rational number
as a conceptual entity.
Well, what's the
advantage of that?
What's the advantage
of isolating
the idea of rational numbers
as a conceptual entity,
and really naming it
with make-RAT, numerator,
and denominator.
Well, one advantage is
you might want to have
alternative representations.
See, before I showed you
that one way George can solve
this things not reduced
to lowest terms problem,
is when you build
a rational number,
you divide up by the
greatest common denominator.
Another way to do that
is shown over here.
I can have an alternative
representation
for rational numbers where when
you make a rational number,
you just cons them.
However, when you
go to select out
the numerator, at that point
you compute the gcd of the stuff
that's sitting in that pair,
and divide out by the gcd.
And similarly, when I
get the denominator,
at that point when I go
to get the denominator,
I'll divide out by the gcd.
So the difference would be in
the old representation, when
ans was constructed
here, say what's 6 and 8,
in the first way,
the 6 and 8 would
have got reduced when they
got stuck into that pair,
numerator would select out 3.
And in the way I
just showed you,
well, ans would
get 6 and 8 put in,
and then at the point
where I said numerator,
some computation would get
done to put out 3 instead of 6.
So those are two different
ways I might do it.
Which one's better?
Well, it depends, right?
If I'm making a system
where I am mostly
constructing rational numbers
and hardly ever looking
at them, then it's
probably better
not to do that gcd computation
when I construct them.
If I'm doing a system where
I look at things a lot more
than I construct them,
then it's probably better
to do the work when
I construct them.
So there's a choice there.
But the real issue
is that you might not
be able to decide at the
moment you're worrying
about these rational numbers.
See, in general, as
systems designers,
you're forced with the
necessity to make decisions
about how you're
going to do things,
and in general, the way you'd
like to retain flexibility
is to never make up
your mind about anything
until you're forced to do it.
The problem is, there's
a very, very narrow line
between deferring decisions
and outright procrastination.
So you'd like to make progress,
but also at the same time,
never be bound by the
consequences of your decisions.
Data abstraction's
one way of doing this.
What we did is we
used wishful thinking.
See, we gave a name
to the decision.
We said, make-RAT,
numerator, and denominator
will stand for however
it's going to be done,
and however it's going to
be done is George's problem.
But really, what that was
doing is giving a name
to the decision of how
we're going to do it,
and then continuing as
if we made the decision.
And then eventually, when
we really wanted it to work,
coming back and facing
what we really had to do.
And in fact, we'll see
a couple times from now
that you may never
have to choose
any particular
representation, ever, ever.
Anyway, that's a very
powerful design technique.
It's the key to the reason
people use data abstraction.
And we're going to see
that idea again and again.
Let's stop for questions.
AUDIENCE: What does
this decision making
through abstraction layers do to
the axiom of do all your design
before any of your code?
PROFESSOR: Well,
that's someone's axiom,
and I bet that's the
axiom of someone who
hasn't implemented very large
computer systems very much.
I said that computer
science is a lot like magic,
and it's sort of good
that it's like magic.
There's a bad part
of computer science
that's a lot like religion.
And in general, I
think people who
really believe that you design
everything before you implement
it basically are people
who haven't designed
very many things.
The real power is
that you can pretend
that you've made the
decision and then later
on figure out which one is
right, which decision you ought
to have made.
And when you can do that, you
have the best of both worlds.
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain the difference
between let and define?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
Let is a way to
establish local names.
Let me give you sort
of the half answer.
And I'll say, later on we
can talk about the whole very
complicated thing.
But the big difference
for now is that, see,
when you're typing
at Lisp, you're
typing in this environment
where you're making definitions.
And when you say define a to be
5, if I say define a to be 5,
then from then on the thing
will remember that a is 5.
Let is a way to set up
a local context where
there's a definition.
So if I type something
like, saying let a-- no,
I shouldn't say
a-- if I said let z
be 10, and within that context,
tell me what the sum of z and z
is.
So if I typed in this expression
to Lisp, and then this
would put out 20.
However, then if
I said what's z,
the computer would say
that's an unbound variable.
So let is a way of
setting up a context where
you can make definitions.
But those definitions are
local to this context.
And of course, if I'd said
a in here, I'd still get 20.
But this a would not interfere
at all with this one.
So if I type this, and then type
this, and then say what's a?
a will still be 5.
So there's some other
subtle differences
between let and define, but
that's the most important one.
All right, well, we've looked at
implementing this little system
for doing arithmetic
on rational numbers
as an example of this
methodology of data
abstraction.
And that's a way of controlling
complexity in large systems.
But, see, like
procedure definition,
and like all the
ways we're going
to talk about for
controlling complexity,
the real power of these things
show up not when you sort of do
these things in themselves,
like it's not such a great thing
that we've done rational
number arithmetic,
it's that you can use
these as building blocks
for making more
complicated things.
So it's no wonderful idea that
you can just put two numbers
together to form a pair.
If that's all you
ever wanted to do,
there are tons of ways
that you can do that.
The real issue is can
you do that in such a way
so that the things
that you build
become building blocks for doing
something even more complex?
So whenever someone
shows you a method
for controlling complexity, you
should say, yeah, that's great,
but what can I build with it?
So for example, let me just run
through another thing that's
a lot like the
rational number one.
Suppose we would like to
represent points in the plane.
You sort of say,
well, there's a point,
and we're going to
call that point p.
And that point might
have coordinates,
like this might be
the point 1 comma 2.
The x-coordinate might be 1, and
it's y-coordinate might be 2.
And we'll make a little
system for manipulating points
in the plane.
And again, we can
do that-- here's
a little example of that.
It can represent vectors, the
same as points in the plane,
and we'll say, yep, there's a
constructor called make-vector,
make-vector's going to
take two coordinates,
and here we can implement
them if we like as pairs,
but the important thing is
that there's a constructor.
And then given some vector, p,
we can find its x-coordinate,
or we can get its y-coordinate.
So there's a constructor
and selectors
for points in the plane.
Well, given points
in the plane, we
might want to use them
to build something.
So for instance, we
might want to talk
about, we might have a
point, p, and a point, q,
and p might be the point 1, 2,
and q might be the point 2, 3.
And we might want to talk
about the line segment that
starts at p and ends at q.
And that might be the segment s.
So we might want to
build points for vectors
in terms of numbers, and
segments in terms of vectors.
So we can represent
line segments
in exactly the same way.
All right, so the line
segment from p to q,
we'll say there's a
constructor, make-segment.
And make up names
for the selectors,
the starting point
of the segment
and the ending point
of the segment.
And again, we can implement
a segment using cons
as a pair of points, and car
and cdr get out the two points
that we put together
to get the segment.
Well, now having
done that, we can
have some operations on them.
Like we could say, what's the
midpoint of a line segment?
So here's the midpoint
of a line segment,
that's going to be the
points whose coordinates are
the averages of the
coordinates of the endpoints.
OK, there's the midpoint.
So to get the midpoint
of a line segment,
s, we'll just say grab the
starting point to the segment,
grab the ending
point of the segment,
and now make a vector-- make
a point whose coordinates are
the average of the
x-coordinate of the first point
and the x-coordinate
of the second point,
and whose y-coordinate is the
average of the y-coordinates.
So there's an
implementation of midpoint.
And then similarly,
we can build something
like the length of the segment.
The length of the
segment is a thing
whose-- use Pythagoras's rule,
the length of the segment
is the square root of the d
x squared plus d y squared.
We'll say to get the
length of a line segment,
we'll let dx be the difference
of the x-coordinate of one
endpoint and the x-coordinate
of the other endpoint,
and we'll let dy
be the difference
of the y-coordinates.
And then we'll take
the square root
of the sum of the squares of dx
and dy, that's what this says.
All right, so there's an
implementation of length.
And again, what we built
is a layered system.
We built a system which
has, well, say up here
there's segments.
And then there's an
abstraction barrier.
The abstraction barrier
separates the implementation
of segments from the
implementation of vectors
and points, and what that
abstraction barrier is
are the constructors
and selectors.
It's make-segment, and
segment-start, and segment-end.
And then there are vectors.
And vectors in turn are built
on top of pairs and numbers.
So I'll say pairs and numbers.
And that has its own
abstraction barrier,
which is make-vector, and
x-coordinate, and y-coordinate.
So we have, again,
a layered system.
You're starting to see
that there are layers here.
I ought to mention, there
is a very important thing
that I kind of took for granted.
And it's sort of so natural,
but on the other hand
it's a very important thing.
Notice that in order to
represent this segment
s, I said this segment
is a pair of points.
And a point is a
pair of numbers.
And if I were going to
draw the box and pointers
structure for that, I
would say, oh, the segment
is, given those particular
representations that I showed
you, I'd say this
segment s is a pair,
and the first thing in
the pair is a vector,
and the vector is
a pair of numbers.
And that's this, that's p.
And the other thing
in the segment
is q, which is itself
a pair of numbers.
So I almost took
it for granted when
I said that cons allows
you to put things together.
But it's very easy
to not appreciate
that, because notice, some of
the things I can put together
can themselves be pairs.
And let me introduce a word that
I'll talk about more next time,
it's one of my favorite
words, called closure.
And by closure I mean that
the means of combination
in your system are such that
when you put things together
using them, like we make a pair,
you can then put those together
with the same means
of combination.
So I can have not only
a pair of numbers,
but I can have a pair of pairs.
So for instance, making arrays
in a language like Fortran
is not a closed
means of combination,
because I can make
an array of numbers,
but I can't make
an array of arrays.
And one of the things that you
should ask, one of your tests
of quality for a
means of combination
that someone shows
you, is gee, are
the things you make closed
under that means of combination?
So pairs would not be nearly so
interesting if all I could do
was make a pair of numbers.
I couldn't build very
much structure at all.
OK, well, we'll
come back to that.
I just wanted to mention it now.
You'll hear a lot
about closure later on.
You can also see the
potential for losing control
of complexity as you have
a layered system if you
don't use data abstraction.
Let's go back and look
at this slide for length.
Length works and is a simple
thing because I can say,
when I want to get this
value, I can say, oh,
that is the x-coordinate of the
first endpoint of the segment.
And each of these things,
each of these selectors,
x-coordinate and endpoint,
stand for a decision choice
whose details I don't
have to look at.
So I could perfectly
well, again, just
like rational numbers
I did before, I
could say, oh well,
gee, a segment really
is a pair of pairs.
And the x-coordinate of the
first endpoint or the segment
really is the--
well, what is it?
It's the car of the
car of the segment.
So I could perfectly well
go and redefine length.
I could say, define the
length of some segment s.
And I could start
off writing something
like, well, we'll let dx be--
well, what's it have to be?
It's got to be the difference
of the two coordinates,
so that's the difference
of, the first one is
the car of the car
of s, subtracted
from the first one, the car
of the other half of it,
the cdr of s.
All right, and then
dy would be-- well,
let's see, I'd get
the y-coordinate,
so it'd be the difference
of the cdr of the car of s,
and the cdr of the cdr
of s, sort of go on.
You can see that's
much harder to read
than the program I had before.
But worse than that, suppose
you'd gone and implemented
length?
And then the next day,
George comes to you and says,
I'm sorry, I changed my mind.
I want to write points with
the x-coordinate first.
So you come back you
stare at this code
and say, oh gee, what was that?
That was the car, so I
have to change this to cdr,
and this is cdr, and
this now has to be car.
And this has to be car.
And you sort of
do that, and then
the next day George
comes back and says,
sorry, the guys
designing the display
would like lines to be painted
in the opposite direction,
so I have to write the
endpoint first in the order.
And then you come back and you
stare at this code, and say,
gee, what was it talking about?
Oh yeah, well I've got to
change this one to cdr,
and this one becomes
car, this one comes car,
and this becomes cdr.
And you go up and do that,
and then the next day, George
comes back and says,
I'm sorry, what I really
meant is that the
segments always
have to be painted from
left to right on the screen.
And then you sort
of, it's clear,
you just go and punch George
in the mouth at that point.
But you see, as soon as
we have a 10 layer system,
you see how that complexity
immediately builds up
to the point where even
something like this
gets out of control.
So again, the way we've
gotten out of that
is we've named that spirit.
We built a system where
there is a thing, which
is the representation
choice for how you're
going to talk about vectors.
And choices about
that representation
are localized right there.
They don't have
their guts spilling
over into things like how
you compute the length
and how you compute
the midpoint.
And that's the real
power of this system.
OK, we're explicit
about them, so
that we have control over them.
All right, questions?
AUDIENCE: What happens
in the case where
you don't want to be treating
objects in terms of pairs?
For instance, in
three-dimensional space,
you'd have three coordinates.
Or even in the case where you
have n-dimensional space, what
happens?
PROFESSOR: Right, OK.
Well, this is a preview
of what I'll say tomorrow.
But the point is, once
you have two things,
you have as many
things as you want.
All right?
Because if I want to
make three things,
I could start making things
like a pair whose first thing is
1, and whose second thing
is another pair that,
say, has 2 and 3 in it.
And so on, a hundred things.
I can nest them out of pairs.
I made a pretty arbitrary
decision about how to do it,
and you can
immediately see there
are lots of ways to do that.
What we'll start
talking about next time
are conventions for how
to do things like that.
But notice that what this
really depends on is I
can make pairs of pairs.
If all I could do was make
pairs of numbers, I'd be stuck.
OK.
Let's break.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, well,
we've just gone off
and done a couple of simple
examples of data abstraction.
Now I want to do something
more complicated.
We're going to talk
about what it means.
And this will be harder,
because it's always
much harder in
computer programming
to talk about what something
means than to go off and do it.
But let's go back to
almost the very beginning.
Let's go back to the
point where I said,
we just assumed that there
were procedures, make-RAT,
and numer, and denom.
Let's go back to where we had
this, at the very beginning,
constructors and
selectors, and went off
and defined the rational
number arithmetic.
And remember, I
said at that point
we were sort of done,
except for George.
Well, what is it that we'd
actually done at that point?
What was it that was done?
Well, what I want
to say is, what
was done after we'd
implemented the operations
and terms of these, was that we
had defined a rational number
representation in
terms of abstract data.
What do I mean by abstract data?
Well, the idea is
that at that point,
when we had our
+RAT and our *RAT,
that any implementation of
make-RAT, and numerator,
and denominator that
George supplied us with,
could be the basis for a
rational number representation.
Like, it wasn't our concern
where you divided through
to get the greatest common
denominator, or any of that.
So the idea is
that what we built
is a rational arithmetic
system that would sit
on top of any representation.
What do I mean by
any representation?
I mean, certainly it can't
be the case that all I mean
is George can reach
in a bag and pull out
three arbitrary procedures
and say, well, fine,
now that's the implementation.
That can't be what I mean.
What I've got to
mean is that there's
some way of saying whether
three procedures are
going to be suitable as a
basis for rational number
representation.
If we think about
it, what suitable
might mean is if I have to
assume something like this,
I have to say that if
x is the result of say,
doing make-RAT of n and d,
then the numerator of x divided
by the denominator of
x is equal to n over d.
See, what that is is
that's George's contract.
What we mean by writing a
contract for rational numbers,
if you think about it,
this is the right thing.
And the two ones we
showed do the right thing.
See, if I'm taking out
greatest common divisors,
it doesn't matter whether
I take them out or not,
or the place where I take
them, because the idea is I'm
going to divide through.
But see, this is
George's contract.
So what we really
say to George is
your business is to
go off and find us
three procedures,
make-RAT, and numerator,
and denominator, that
fulfill this contract
for any choice of n and d.
And that's what we
mean by we can use that
as the basis for a rational
number representation.
And other than that, it
fulfills this contract.
We don't care how he does it.
It's not our business.
It's below the layer
of abstraction.
In fact, if we want to say, what
is a rational number really?
See, what's it
really, without having
to talk about going below the
layer of abstraction, what
we're forced into saying
is a rational number
really is sort of this
axiom, is three procedures,
make-RAT, numerator,
and denominator,
that satisfy this axiom.
In some sense,
abstractly, that's
what a rational
number is really.
That's sort of easy
words to listen to,
because what you have
in your head, of course,
is well, for all this
thing about saying
that's what a rational
number is really,
you actually just saw that
we built rational numbers.
See, what we really did is
we built rational numbers
on top of pairs.
So for all I'm
saying abstractly,
we can say a rational number
really is just this axiom.
You can listen to
that comfortably,
because you're
saying, well, yeah,
but really it's actually pairs,
and I'm just annoying you
by trying to be abstract.
Well, let me, as an
antidote for that,
let me do something that I think
is really going to terrify you.
I mean, it's really
going to bring
you face to face with the
sort of existential reality
of this abstraction that
we're talking about.
And what I'm going to talk
about is, what are pairs really?
See, what did I tell
you about pairs?
I tricked you, right?
I said that Lisp has
this primitive called
cons that builds pairs.
But what did I really
tell you about?
If you go back and said,
let's look on this slide,
all I really told
you about pairs
is that there happens to be
this property, these properties
of cons, car, and
cdr. And all I really
said about pairs is that
there's a thing called cons,
and a thing called car,
and a thing called cdr.
And it is the case that
if I build cons of x, y
and take car of it, I get x.
And if I build cons of x, y
and get cdr of it, I get y.
And even though I lulled you
into thinking that there's
something in Lisp that does
that, so you pretended you knew
what it was, in fact, I
didn't tell you any more
about pairs than this tells
you about rational numbers.
It's just some axiom for pairs.
Well, to drive that
home, let me really
scare you, and show you what we
might build pairs in terms of.
And what you're going
to see is that we
can build rational
numbers, and line segments,
and vectors, and all of this
stuff in terms of pairs,
and we're going to see
below here that pairs can
be built out of nothing at all.
Pure abstraction.
So let me show you on this
slide an implementation
of cons, car, and cdr. And we'll
look at it again in a second,
but notice that their procedure
definitions of cons, car,
and cdr, you don't see any
data in there, what you see
is a lambda.
So cons here is
going to return--
is a procedure that
returns a procedure, just
like AVERAGE DAMP.
Cons of a and b returns a
procedure of an argument
called pick, and it says,
if pick is equal to 1,
I'm going to return a,
and if pick is equal to 2,
I'm going to return
b, and that's
what cons is going to be.
Car of a thing x,
car of a pair x,
is going to be x applied to 1.
And notice that makes sense.
You might not understand why
or how I'm doing such a thing,
but at least it makes sense,
because the thing constructed
by cons is a procedure,
and car applies that to 1.
And similarly, cdr
applies that thing to 2.
OK, now I claimed that this is
a representation of cons, car,
and cdr, and notice
there's no data in it.
All right, it's
built out of air.
It's just procedures.
There's no data objects at
all in that representation.
Well, what could
that possibly mean?
Well, if you really
believe this stuff,
then you have to
believe that in order
to show that that's a
representation for cons, car,
and cdr, all I
have to do is show
that it satisfies the axiom.
See, all I should have
to convince you of
is, for example, that gee,
that car of cons of 37 and 49
is 37 for arbitrary
values of 37 and 49.
And cdr the same way.
See, if I really can
demonstrate to you
that that weird procedure
definition, in terms
of [? air ?], has the property
that it satisfies this,
then you just have
to grant me that that
is a possible implementation of
cons, car, and cdr, on which I
can build everything else.
Well, let's look at that.
And this will be practice
in the substitution model.
How could we check this?
We sort of know how to do that.
It's just the same
substitution model.
Let's look.
We start out, and we say,
what's car of cons of 37 and 49?
What do we do?
Cons is some procedure.
Its value is cons was
a procedure of a and b.
The thing returned by
cons is its procedure body
with 37 and 49 substituted
for the parameters.
It'll be 37 substituted for
a and 49 substituted for b.
So this expression has the same
meaning as this expression.
Its car of, and the body
of cons was this thing
that started with lambda.
And it says, so if
pick is equal to 1,
where pick is this
other argument,
if pick is equal to 1, it's
37, that's where a was,
and if pick is
equal to 2, it's 49.
So that's the first step.
I'm just going through
mechanical substitution.
And remember, at this
point in the course,
if you're confused
about what things mean,
go mechanically through
the substitution model.
Well, what is this reduced to?
Car said, take your argument,
which in this case is this,
and apply it to 1.
That was the definition of car.
So if I look at car, if
I do that, the answer is,
well, it's that argument,
this was the argument to car,
applied to 1.
Well, what does that mean?
I take 1, and I
substitute it in the body
here for this value
of pick, which
is the name of the
argument, what do I get?
Well, I get the thing that
says if 1 equals 1 it's 37,
and if 1 equals 2 it's
49, so the answer's 37.
And similarly, if I'd taken
cdr, that would apply it to 2,
and I'd get 49.
So you see, what
I've demonstrated
is that that completely weird
implementation of cons, car,
and cdr, satisfies the axioms.
So it's a perfectly
valid way of building,
in fact, all of the data objects
we're going to see in Lisp.
So they all, if you
like, can be built
on sort of existential nothing.
And as far as you know,
that's how it works.
You couldn't tell.
If all you're ever
going to do with pairs
is construct them with cons and
look at them with car and cdr,
you couldn't possibly
tell how this thing works.
Now, it might give you a sort
of warm feeling inside if I say,
well, yeah, in fact, for
various reasons there happens
to be a primitive called
cons, car, and cdr,
and if it's too scary, if this
kind of stuff is too scary,
you don't have to
look inside of it.
So that might make
you feel better,
but the point is, it
really could work this way,
and it wouldn't
make any difference
to the system at all.
So in some sense, we
don't need data at all
to build these
data abstractions.
We can do everything
in terms of procedures.
OK, well, why did I
terrify you in this way?
First, I really
want to reinforce
this idea of abstraction,
that you really
can do these things abstractly.
Secondly, I want to
introduce an idea
we're going to see more and
more of in this course, which
is we're going to blur the
line between what's data
and what's a procedure.
See, in this funny
implementation
it turned out that
cons of something
happened to be represented
in terms of a procedure,
even though we
think of it as data.
While here that's sort
of a mathematical trick,
but one of the
things we'll see is
that a lot of the very
important programming
techniques that we're
going to get to sort of
depend very
crucially on blurring
this traditional line between
what you consider a procedure
and what you consider data.
We're going to see more and more
of that, especially next time.
OK, questions?
AUDIENCE: If you
asked the system
to print a, what would happen?
PROFESSOR: The question
is, what would happen if I
asked the system to print a.
Given this representation,
you already know the answer.
The answer is compound procedure
a, just like last time.
It'd say compound procedure.
It might say a little bit more.
It might say compound procedure
lambda or something or other,
depending on details
of how I named it.
But it's a procedure.
And the only reason
for that is I
haven't told the
system anything special
about how to print such things.
Now, it's in fact true that
with the actual implementation
of cons that to be
built in the system,
it would print something else.
It would print,
say, this is a pair.
AUDIENCE: When you
define cons, and then you
pass it into values,
how does it know
where to look for the cons,
because you can use cons
over and over again?
How does it know where to
look to know which a and b
it's supposed to pull back out?
I don't know if I'm
expressing that quite right.
Where is it stored?
PROFESSOR: OK, the
question is, I sort of have
a cons with a 37 and a 49,
and I might make another cons
with a 1 and a 2, and I
might have one called a,
and I might have one called b.
And the question is,
how does it know?
And why don't they get confused?
And that's a very good question.
See, you have to really
believe that the procedures are
objects.
It's sort of like saying-- let's
try another simpler example.
Suppose I ask for
the square root of 3.
So I asked for the
square root of 5,
and then I ask for
the square of 20.
You're probably
not the least bit
bothered that I can take
square root and apply it to 5,
and then I can take square
root and apply it to 20.
And there's sort
of no issue, gee,
doesn't it get confused
about whether it's
working on 5 or 20?
There's no issue about
that because you're
thinking of a procedure which
goes off and does something.
Now, in some sense you're
asking me the same question.
But it's really bothering
you, and it's bothering you
for a really good reason.
Because when I write that,
you're saying gee, this is,
I know, sort of a procedure.
But it's not a procedure
that's just running.
It's just sort of a
procedure sitting there.
And how can it be that sometimes
this procedure has 37 and 49,
and there might be another one
which has 5 and 6 in there,
and why don't they get confused?
So there's something very, very
important that's bothering you.
And it's really crucial
to what's going on.
We're suddenly saying that
procedures are not just the act
of doing something.
Procedures are conceptual
entities, objects,
and if I built
cons of 37 and 49,
that's a particular
procedure that sits there.
And it's different
from cons of 3 and 4.
That's another procedure
that sits there.
AUDIENCE: Both of them
exist independently.
PROFESSOR: And
exists independently.
AUDIENCE: And they both can
be referenced by car and cdr.
PROFESSOR: And they both would
Just like I could
increment this,
and I could increment that.
They're objects.
And that's sort of
where we're going.
See, the fact that you're
asking the question
shows that you're
really starting
to think about the implications
of what's going on.
It's the difference between
saying a procedure is just
the act of doing something.
And a procedure is a real
object that has existence.
AUDIENCE: So when the
procedure gets built,
the actual values are now
substituted for a and b--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: And then that
procedure exists as lambda,
and pick is what's
actually passed in.
PROFESSOR: Yes, when cons gets
called, and the result of cons
is a new procedure
that's constructed,
that new procedure has an
argument that's called pick.
AUDIENCE: But it no
longer has an a and b.
The a and b are the actual
values that are passed through.
PROFESSOR: And it has-- right,
according to the substitution
model, what it now has is not
those arbitrary names a and b,
it somehow has that
37 and 49 in there.
But you're right, that's a
hard thing to think about it,
and it's different
from the way you've
been thinking about procedures.
AUDIENCE: And if I have
again cons of 37 and 49,
it's a different object?
PROFESSOR: And if you make
another cons of 37 and 49,
you're into a wonderful
philosophical problem, which
is going to be what the
lecture about halfway
through this course is about.
Which is, if I cons 37
and 49, and I do it again,
is that the same thing, or
is it a different thing?
And how could you tell?
And when could it
possibly matter?
And that's sort of like saying,
is that the same thing as this?
Or is this the
same thing as that?
It's the same kind of question.
And that's a very,
very deep question.
And I can't answer
in less than an hour.
But we will.